[Musica]
[Applauso]
bello questo piatto vero adesso ve lo
spiego la cosa più importante quando si
fa un piatto è riuscire a fare in modo
che i nostri ospiti dopo averlo
assaggiato se lo ricordino per sempre
per questo oltre a essere buono un
piatto deve avere anche una storia da
raccontare
deve avere un'idea nel in questo caso la
glaciazione del worm un evento che
10.000 anni fa ha permesso al salmerino
alpino di diffondersi sulle alpi nei
laghi delle alpi e solo in pochi laghi
del trentino si è conservato per fino ai
giorni nostri
e proprio per questo la scienza lo anche
definito un relitto glaciale deve poi
essere espressione del territorio ma
vivendo da 10.000 anni nei laghi del
trentino e fortemente identificativo
deve avere una novità avere una tecnica
nuova
avete visto che io ho versato un liquido
non è altro che acqua e sale è una
soluzione satura di accettato di sodio
che rimane liquido finché non viene
perturbato da quella bustina con
all'interno del ginepro e dell'olio
essenziale al pino mugo tornando solido
rilascia calore questo calore crea
ricrea una sensazione dell'ambiente di
montagna avvolge gli ospiti suggerendo
l'ambiente della montagna un piatto poi
deve anche stupire e l'amaranto è un
ingrediente lontano che uno non si
aspetterebbe in un piatto così
apparentemente sconnesso ma
riconducibile per per l'esperienza del
del fuoco per la mia esperienza
lavorare in questo modo rende la
professione del cuoco straordinariamente
coinvolgente perché rappresenta ciò che
si è
ciò che si sente di essere io ho
iniziato a fare questo lavoro quando ero
un ragazzo ero affascinato dalle mani di
mia nonna che vedevo impastare gli
gnocchi
così ho frequentato la scuola
alberghiera mi sono diplomato ho
lavorato in grandi alberghi in italia e
all'estero e sono stato al fianco di un
grande maestro gualtiero marchesi
tutto questo potrebbe farvi pensare che
io avessi sempre avuto una visione
nitida un'idea chiara della mia
professione
eppure non è così ho capito di amare
veramente la cucina
solo pochi mesi fa e l'ho capito grazie
ad una crisi una profonda crisi
personale che alla fine dell'anno scorso
mi stava togliendo la passione mi stava
togliendo l'entusiasmo mi rendeva
scontroso e lentamente consumava anche
la fede in me stesso
non credevo più nelle mie possibilità
sta di fatto che mi sono trovato di
fronte ad un bivio o mollare tutto
oppure ripartire ho scelto di ripartire
e l'ho fatto tornando ad un mondo che
sentivo vicino il mondo delle mie
origini quello della montagna con i suoi
ritmi i suoi paesaggi con il gusto delle
cose semplici
comunque sono ripartito da un viaggio
un'avventura semplice attraverso le alpi
che ho pensato e sviluppato seguendo una
logica del rispetto e del risparmio di
risorse cercando di restituire
l'ambiente così come l'ho trovato senza
lasciare tracce muovendomi
esclusivamente in cammino
oppure volando in parapendio sono
partito sono partito da trento con
l'idea di arrivare a pollenzo in
piemonte alla facoltà di scienze
gastronomiche
volevo che questo viaggio forse
significativo per me ma anche per il mio
modo di essere e per il mio lavoro
così ho fatto una prima tappa al
giardino botanico alpino
qui al monte bondone alle viote sono
passato dall amico norbert niederkofler
autore di una cucina di montagna etica e
rispettosa
ho visitato il museo di messner a plan
de corones e in val d'ultimo insieme ad
alcuni amici che mi avevano raggiunto ho
sperimentato quella che amo definire una
cucina di prossimità estemporanea
pensate che per 20 giorni ho camminato
risalendo le montagne ho volato
attraverso le a attraverso le dolomiti
il vallese il monte bianco
ho visto scenari straordinari
ho anche incontrato difficoltà ed ho
sofferto tanto che in alcuni casi stavo
quasi pensando di abbandonare invece ho
continuato
sentivo la voglia di continuare sentivo
la necessità di stare da solo di
ritrovare tempo per pensare per guardare
per dormire
ed in questi momenti di solitudine e
contemplazione
ho ritrovato una connessione qualcosa ha
iniziato a riattivarsi a rigenerarsi ho
ritrovato l'entusiasmo ritrovato
l'energia
mi sono sentito più forte è anche più
giovane per questo vorrei lasciarvi un
messaggio che sento nel valore del volo
perché il volo è conoscenza relazione
intima con l'ambiente ma anche con con
se stessi con i propri limiti
il volo è scuola di vita e carattere ci
insegna a riconoscere la passione la
tenacia il coraggio il volo equilibrio è
lo stesso che cerco nei miei piatti e
l'armonia la capacità di far convivere
due elementi distanti il vole bellezza
ed è coraggio il coraggio di ripartire
di rompere gli schemi di uscire dalle
convenzioni l'educazione ci rende
adeguati alla società ma spesso limita e
atrofizza le nostre qualità
chi vola invece ha voglia di andare
oltre e tutte le volte che decolla
tutte le volte che muove il primo passo
sa che da quel momento in poi accetta un
rischio ma sa anche che avrà dei momenti
bellissimi
un regalo intenso fatto di bellezza e di
profumi e di colori
questo viaggio questo volo mi ha aperto
gli occhi mi ha fatto capire che tutti
questi valori li potevo ritrovare nella
cucina in quello che faccio tutti i
giorni nella creazione di un piatto
nelle difficoltà che condivido con i
miei ragazzi nella scelta dei prodotti
migliori nell'uso della tecnica mi sono
reso conto che il volo rappresenta ciò
che stavo cercando nella mia cucina e
così sono tornato da questo viaggio con
uno sguardo nuovo con una fiducia è una
forza nuova
ora dopo avervi raccontato questa mia
storia
la ricerca del viaggio le emozioni del
volo vorrei che anche voi provaste a
volare pensate al vostro lavoro oa
quello che fate nella vostra vita
poi pensate a un avo nostra grande
passione
cercate e combinate i valori che questi
due mondi così lontani e apparentemente
opposti condividono trovare questi
valori capire cosa muove veramente la
passione dentro di voi questo è volare
ora vi saluto con un verso di montale a
cui sono particolarmente affezionato e
che qui oggi evoca un po il senso di
tutta la mia storia la necessità di
trovare un equilibrio di trovare
un'armonia chi trascina i piedi nel
fango
ma gli occhi nelle stelle quello è il
vero eroe
quello è il soul vivente grazie
[Applauso]